I'm Chris Lane and you're watching
behind the scenes for the border music
I welcome to set my name is TK McCamey
and we were here today shooting chris
lanes for her music video you know Chris
and I were talking about what the music
video would look like and we didn't want
to shoot just the typical make up love
story of him and some girl we're just
like let's do something real let's give
the people authenticity so we found
Brandon it's been in love with this girl
for two plus years and it's been saving
for 2 plus years and and she's an
amazing woman and really excited to be a
part of their story
that you play
Brenda and I are about to do the opening
shots of the video where we do our
little interview style this girlfriend
Connie has no clues she's walking onto
the set of a music video where she's
about to legitly propose to Connie
thinks that her friend Tara has won a
radio contest but Tara is my inside mole
I cannot wait to happen she has she has
no idea no idea whatsoever once about
that much birth Tara's not only
convinced Connie that she's won five VIP
passes to the set of my music video but
she's convinced Connie to come with her
and to bring Brandon she has no idea if
that's happening obviously but he is
never sung karaoke is life he is never
sang on a microphone on his life and he
has never been in front of anyone like
on a stage
windows
right so yeah like never even drunken
karaoke is none of that milk ever it's
so out of my element
well that's wrap Chris Lane killed it
proposal where amazingly well she said
yes
thank the Lord everything's awesome it's
going to be this beautifully encouraging
love story I can't wait for everybody to
see
congrats to Connie and Brandon there's
been a great day
I can't wait for y'all to see this video
was it a lot of work into it so you
better watch you
you